you wrote a huge book on democracy and
the history of democracy in America when
you read that for normal but one of the
things you start to realize that
everything was going on now with Trump
and the GOP Republican Party and in
certain way there is not that much knew
what's going on American democracy that
you always have had those extremes well
there are always these tensions and
American Life petitions about ethnicity
of class of race to beauty to be sure
that come get recombined the different
permutations and combinations of those
forces they evolve they take on
different shapes but they're there and
they're always there I don't think we've
had anybody quite like Niall drunk
before in terms of the politics of
celebrity which is what I think is
really about it's not something that
he's rich we've had rich people on
politics before it's not simply a
businessman we've had businessmen in
politics before but to be able to build
up this kind of demagogic celebrity that
is something that we never quite seen
before it went that way but he's playing
on very old themes he moved up in the
polls very dramatically when he started
talking about Mexican immigrants and and
building a wall all the rest of it
tapping into a kind of nativist
frustration that's been there in
American politics for a very long time
it's combined with an anti political or
anti-politician note which always has
been a part of American nativism I
should add I mean it's the nativism is
not only about the immigrants it's also
about the corrupt political system that
is allied with the immigrants that lets
them in well he's played that to a tee
so in some ways you could look at Donald
Trump and look at the natives movement
of say the 1850s and imagine not much
has changed that's true but the
situation is different and Trump is
different and the kinds of you know the
America is different so you taught us we
taught us but the themes are still very
much there here what is not different
they said when Alexis de Tocqueville
came to America around his great book on
democracy in the USA on democracy in
America he wrote it for Europeans
he wrote it as he
right in his preface that we Europeans
have to understand portacaval America
because and welcome to Europe as well
now with these elections you hear a lot
of times the system is broke our
democracy is dysfunctional what is true
about that again for us Europeans it's
important to know because you know may
come to Europe as well I don't think
that American democracy is broken I
think American democracies are no crisis
at the moment a political crisis but
it's going to be worked out one way or
the other they say there's nothing about
there's nothing bad with America that
one good election can't cure well that's
an optimistic view it's also mine you
can also have a band election but at the
moment 2016 I do think we're at one of
those crossroads where I mean lately
talked about the house divided in 1858
was about slavery the country was going
to become either one thing or the other
I think we're to cross those like that
now in 2016 if we go in one direction
the Republican Party which is become a
very very conservative party to say the
least
well control of every level of American
government and would then take retake
the the Supreme Court that would be a
very different outcome in a the
Democrats won but the Democrats would
then be appointed being this report
would presumably have control of the
Senate as well as the White House and
maybe even make gains in the house those
are starkly different paths given the
the nature of the parties today so we
are at that moment right now but but
what we see is the dysfunction I think
it's just a prelude to the settlement of
that crisis one way or the other